BILL BILLENSTEIN: Well,
welcome, everybody.
I see a lot of familiar faces.
But for those of you who don't
know, I am Chef Bill
Billenstein from the Silicon
Beach Cafe here at Google.
And today we're very proud
to have Amelia
Saltsman, local cook.
She made sure that I tell you
that she is not a chef.
She's a cook.
And she wants you to be
able to cook, too.
Amelia has written this
wonderful farmers' market
cookbook, "The Santa Monica
Farmers' Market Cookbook."
She's also a contributor to
KCRW's "Good Food." She is on
the board of the Garden
City Food Foundation.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Garden
School Foundation.
BILL BILLENSTEIN: Garden
School Food Foundation.
She's here today to go through
a couple rapid fire recipes
and show you the bounty of the
seasons and some delicious
things that you can
do with your local
farmer's market produce.
So without further
ado, Amelia.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Thank
you, Chef.
[APPLAUSE]
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Well, I am
delighted to be here.
And Chef, you pretty well nailed
it, what I'm all about.
What I do is I really like
to help people see the
connections between
their food.
Well, I should say
among because
there are lots of things.
The food that they eat, what it
does for our health, what
it does for the planet.
All the things we sort of
worry about in life, the
answer is actually
really simple--
start with flavorful,
fresh ingredients.
It's the fastest, easiest
way to healthy,
delicious cooking fast.
So I'm going to get
this started.
I'm going to put a little olive
oil in here and throw
some onions in that I've
already chopped.
And I'm going to get that going
while I introduce a
little bit more of
what we're doing.
And it's going to take
us a little time to
get adjusted here.
So how many of you shop at
farmers' markets beyond what
is brought to you here?
You are so lucky.
Yeah?
OK, great.
So I'm preaching to the
converted, right?
But how many of you are a little
bit confused about what
to do with some of the stuff?
Don't have time?
Maybe it's hard?
You feel like the window of what
you're trying is a little
bit narrow, like there's
a lot of--
yeah?
A lot of ingredients,
but you're not sure
what to do with them?
So what I want to do today is
try to get through as many
things as we can, answering
questions as we go and try to
show you some of the techniques,
the simple
techniques that you need that
you can just then vary
everything through all
of these vegetables.
Now, I'm not a vegetarian and
this isn't vegetarian cooking.
And my cookbook, "The Santa
Monica Farmers' Market
Cookbook" is--
it covers everything.
It covers sustainably raised
meats and eggs and poultry,
all the things that we should
be looking to find as
carefully grown as we can.
Because the key to all
of this is flavor.
Chef and I were just talking,
if you start with the most
delicious ingredients, you'd
really have to do very little.
So that's the trick to cooking
fast and simply.
Another little trick is
to layer flavors.
So I've got some onions
sauteing.
So this first dish we're going
to do is a saute dish.
That's a great technique.
So what you want to do is, with
whatever your cooking,
don't add all the salt,
let's say, at once.
Add a little bit at a time.
That's such an easy technique,
but it will deepen and make
more complex all the flavors
that you're doing.
So we're going to do a Swiss
chard dish first.
Are you all familiar
with Swiss chard?
You all use it?
OK.
Because Cat told me, she's like,
always like I'm not sure
what to do with Swiss chard.
And this technique
works with kale.
It works with other
quick cooking
greens, as for all fabulous.
So basically, we want to
look for contrast.
We're going to do onions.
We're going to do
earthy greens.
We're going to give it some
heat from red pepper.
And we're going to give it some
sweetness from raisins.
So that's another great
technique, contrasting flavors.
Very exciting, really
easy to do.
That's why we all like
salty sweet, right?
Because it's contrasting
flavor.
So one of the things about
cooking fast is,
how do you do it?
So like that.
Don't take a knife and
start cutting.
Want to see it again?
I love this trick.
A farmer taught me.
OK?
Now, with Swiss chard, you
can use the stalk.
It sort of has the texture
of celery.
So I've cut up a bunch
here, because we
already separated out.
So I'm going to start it with
the onions because it takes a
little bit longer to cook
than the leaves.
And another trick is that we
don't want to add a whole lot
of liquid to the pan, because
we want the flavors to come
from the vegetables.
Because if you add a lot of
liquid, you're going to have
boiled vegetables.
And there's nothing really
exciting about that.
So now that I've got these
fabulous-looking leaves, all I
need to do-- can you all see?
OK.
Let me set this aside.
AUDIENCE: Can you
move that bowl?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: This one?
OK, I'm going to set it aside
right here until we're
ready to use it.
OK, so now, like if
I were rolling a
lot of tobacco leaves.
Now I'm going to cut
it assembly line
into these nice strips.
And now that's ready.
And that's only going to take
a couple of minutes to cook.
So what you want to do is soften
the onions, get them
starting to turn sweet.
And the chard stems.
So now what you also
have is texture.
You've got a contrasting
texture.
So in about two minutes, we've
hit all these great marks.
Right But all we've done
is cook a little
onion and chard stems.
OK.
So we are going to
add the chard.
And it might take a little
bit more time to--
we might have to do
it in batches.
Little salt.
And it's going to wilt
down pretty quickly.
And you notice, we still haven't
added any water, any
liquid to the pan.
And as it's cooking down, I'm
just going to add more.
So this is two bunches
of chard.
And you know, this happens
to have white stems.
But you've seen chard
also comes rainbow.
Does this remind you an
anything, any other vegetable?
AUDIENCE: Beets.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Beets.
Beets, I didn't hear you?
OK.
So very close relative.
Farmers would say that
chard is really a
beet without a root.
That's how closely related.
So that means if you
buy beets, don't
throw the tops away.
You can cook them
just like this.
I like to call that a twofer.
And actually, with fresh beets,
the tops are the most
nutritious.
It's like any dark,
leafy green.
It's really good for you.
Very good value.
And here we go.
Can I give that to you?
Thanks.
This is Janine, everybody.
Oh, and guess what I
forgot to put in?
I forgot to add the garlic.
So I'm just going to stick it
right here on the side.
And I want you to take
a look at this.
Now, does this look like
sliced garlic that
you're used to seeing?
No.
So I'm going to stick it in.
I'm going to show you a little
interesting factoid.
And you notice I'm not
using a lot of oil.
Do you see how the color
is brightening?
Once the color is bright, we're
going to add our raisins.
And let's add a nice pinch
of red pepper.
Now, I'm going to
cover the pan--
very big technique.
But that's an important
technique.
And can you see how
it's cooking down?
I'm going to cover the
pan, which will allow
the steam to develop.
And I'm hoping that that's going
to be enough moisture to
soften the chard enough.
And it just needs to cook,
maybe 5 minutes
or so, 5 or 10 minutes.
If it cooks longer that's OK.
But if you're in a hurry,
that's OK too.
And I'm going to check
it in a few minutes.
If it seems like it's dry or
sticking, I'll add a little
bit of water.
Otherwise, I'm good.
So let me show you the garlic.
AUDIENCE: Question.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you chop the raisin
or just use them whole?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: OK, I just
threw the raisins in.
And by the way, these
are raisins
produced by a grape grower.
I bought the raisins at the
farmers' market directly from
the producer.
So they are this season's
grapes, or from last summer.
And it makes a really
big difference.
So the steam is going to soften
the raisins as well.
So it's doing its thing.
I'm not doing much.
So garlic.
Everything has a season.
And we're used to seeing
dried bulbs of garlic.
But what we've got here
is late spring garlic.
In the beginning
of the season--
OK, these are baby leeks.
They're not garlic.
But in the beginning, garlic
looks like this.
Slim hips and no cloves.
As the plant grows, the bulb
forms, the cloves form.
Can I give you that?
And you can start to see
the cloves forming.
So I used late spring garlic.
When it's young, you
can use the tops.
These are already getting
too tough to use.
So I'm going to take
the carrots.
So we're going to let that cook
and we're going to make a
carrot dish.
Do you have any other questions
about that?
Besides chopping raisins?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMELIA SALTSMAN: No.
So it's very juicy.
Green garlic is very
mild in flavor.
It has kind of an herbaceous,
sweet garlic flavor.
And this is a perfect
time to use it.
As the plant develops, it
gets stronger in flavor.
So grilling, another
great technique.
Roasting, another great
technique, but we don't have
an oven here.
But we'll talk about
that in a second.
So instead of putting oil on the
grill, I'm putting oil--
a little bit of oil--
on the carrots.
And I'll tell you more about
the carrots in a minute.
So I like sweet and spicy.
So carrots are really
sweet by themselves.
A little salt right
in the bowl.
Now, I've blanched these carrots
before I started.
You all familiar
with that term?
Blanching means to boil just
briefly in salted water, and
then drain it.
And then, shock it with ice and
cold water so that you get
this fabulous--
you preserve the color.
Oh, nice sound.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Did you blanch them
after you cut them?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Yes.
So the question was,
do you blanch them
after you cut them?
And yes, I'm going
to show you--
I'm going to go through
the steps.
What I want to do is get
them on the grill.
And I think you already noticed
that what I've done is
cut them so that I have a really
big cooking surface.
Now, that's a carrot, right?
OK.
So we'll let those go for
a couple minutes.
I'll just set this-- this
is fine right here.
Fabulous variety of carrots.
This is called a Chantenay
variety.
Lots of great carrots
out there.
But your carrot needs to
taste-- this is my
compost bowl here.
Tell me if it's in your way.
Your carrots should taste
really great.
When you cook it briefly,
certain vegetables do better
and their flavors are enhanced,
particularly
vegetables with fat soluble
vitamins like carrots.
So carrots are kind of dense.
They're not filled with water.
But you want it to be really
sweet and you want to heighten
the flavor.
So I'm cutting it at an angle.
And can you hear?
This is not like a super
hard carrot.
Did you see how quickly and
nicely my knife was moving
through it?
So you want this
nice big slabs.
And anything-- little tiny
piece, just eat it because
it's really good, and
good for you.
So I'm going to check
our chard.
Isn't that looking beautiful?
Does it smell good?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: And look at
how pretty the green garlic
got in the dish.
Did you see how all its
pretty little strands?
So we eat with our eyes, too.
We're using all our senses
already and we've only made
one and a half dishes.
So this will be ready
in a minute or two.
And let's see.
What are we ready for?
Let's see how these are doing.
So when you've grilled, one of
the problems with grilling--
everything gets burnt before
it gets cooked.
Oh, somebody's nodding
in agreement.
Indeed.
A couple of little tricks.
Don't have the heat too high.
And vegetables, like
carrots that are
dense, blanch them first.
And then, that way-- and so I
just boiled them until you saw
they were kind of pliable.
Just slightly pliable.
So this big pot full of this
was maybe three minutes.
The nice thing is you
can do that ahead.
Do it the day ahead.
And let's say you're having
people over, then you just
toss those with olive
oil and do it.
And you know how the
other thing is?
Grilling vegetables takes a lot
longer than grilling meat.
Blanch them and it will
take a few minutes.
After that, you can just go on
to grill whatever else you
want to throw on the barbie.
AUDIENCE: Could you do
that for corn too?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Would you do
that for corn too?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: You know what?
I would.
I actually think that
corn needs moisture.
So you can do that by doing it
in the husk because the husk
acts as a natural sealer.
So that's one way
to grill corn.
Another way is to just boil it,
parboil it or blanch it.
And then, just finish it off on
the grill to get that sort
of smoky complexity that
you're looking to
counterbalance with the
sweetness of the vegetable.
So we've got the same thing
happening with the carrots.
Sweet carrots, smoke, heat,
all of those things.
So let's see, I'm going to
need-- how we doing with this?
JANINE: I think they're
almost ready.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: OK.
So what we want-- and
this is not the most
ideal cooking situation.
Now, I don't know if any
of you can see it.
Let's turn that down
a little bit.
But do you see that the carrots
are blistering a
little as well?
That's also because they
were boiled first.
And that sort of blistering,
it's almost like when you're
making pastry and you get these
little layers of air.
It also just enriches
the flavor.
Grilling potatoes--
I would definitely blanch them
first if I wanted to make
spectacular potatoes.
And you see there, what happens
when you're grilling
or roasting is that you're
losing the moisture in the
vegetable and concentrating
the flavor.
So if you don't have great
produce, this will improve
what you have.
If you have this kind of
produce, it will really sing.
It will really sing.
These dishes will be great,
whatever you use.
But if you use this kind of
ingredient, it will be fabulous.
And I hope you'll agree.
One of the things that I did--
speaking of roasting.
I roasted off some
summer squash.
We're just starting
to see this.
And I wanted you to see
what that looks like.
I think you can see
it from here.
All I did was toss it with a
tiny bit of olive oil, a
little salt, and I put it cut
side down on a sheet pan.
And I roasted it for 15,
18 minutes at 425.
And because there's so much
natural sugar in the squash, I
got that beautiful
caramelization.
You won't have that with
industrially produced,
industrially shipped and
distributed ingredients.
You just can't.
So that's what you're
looking for.
So all I did was one knife
cut and I was good.
So with carrots, you
don't need to
blanch them before roasting.
You don't need to blanch
zucchini or summer squash.
But what you do get is--
in fact, roasting is one
of my favorite things.
I have a lot more control.
I don't have to worry
about all of this.
It's just a lot easier.
You can serve it at
room temperature.
And what I want to show you is
we're going to make a couple
of different flavor profiles.
We're going to finish
one batch one way
and one batch another.
But I am going to move
on to tomatoes.
Get that.
So it's not really--
well, let's finish
with this first.
This is done.
All right, what do you think?
Nice?
Now, you can turn this
into a main dish.
I love this dish because it
works a lot of different ways.
You can serve this
as a side dish.
You can toss this with pasta.
You can chop it up and add some
more seasonings and serve
it like as a bruschetta
topping.
And basically, what you're doing
is eating your greens.
Now, what I did today--
are you are familiar
with farro?
Ancient wheat.
Anybody gluten free here?
OK, so this really is--
it's a vegan dish.
I wasn't attempting to
make a vegan dish.
What I'm attempting
to do is have
something really delicious.
And as added value, it happens
to hit all these other marks.
Quinoa would be great.
Rice would be great.
So let's say this is
a building block.
We've got farro.
We've got our greens.
And I think it would look really
beautiful if we just
did that, don't you?
Now, if I wanted to really make
this into a nice main
dish, I could add chick peas.
I could add some of those
carrots, toss it all together
and have a big bowl
of something.
I could season it with cheese.
What other items do you--
what do you like?
AUDIENCE: Steak on top.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: What?
What did you say, Cat?
AUDIENCE: Steak on top.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Steak on top.
Absolutely.
But I think a lot of us know how
to cook a steak, but most
of us have trouble with some
of the vegetables.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Oh, what
was that laughing?
What was that?
Yes?
No?
Do you feel like you
could do this?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Because my goal
here today is for you to
walk away feeling like, you
know, if I have 10 minutes, I
could make dinner.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
preference in the olive oil,
like virgin--
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Extra virgin
olive oil and something that
tastes great.
You know what?
This is the thing--
when you're cooking this simply,
everything better
taste good.
Every ingredient
because there's
nothing to hide behind.
AUDIENCE: Any thoughts on
substituting coconut
oil for olive oil?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: What I would
do, my personal preference--
so the question is substituting
maybe coconut oil
for olive oil.
I like avocado oil.
I like its butteriness.
If you want something
really mild, you
could use avocado oil.
You could use grape seed oil.
So I think that looks pretty
spectacular, right?
If I do say so myself.
So we're building a nice little
buffet here for later.
All right, so now we'll
take the tomatoes.
So it's not really tomato season
here, but it is tomato
season in the desert, where
by the time the rest of
California tomatoes show up,
their season will be done.
So talking about seasonality,
you want to eat in season.
And you say, why are there
already tomatoes?
It's because they're growing
near Palm Springs where it's
really hot.
That's what you want
to look for.
If it's not in season, there's
enough stuff to wait for.
So this is going to be
an early tomato.
Here's another great technique
I'm going to show you.
We're going to make an instant
cold tomato soup.
And the better the tomato,
the better the soup.
So I'm making this today, but
in August, the soup is going
to be ethereal.
Because the better the tomato,
the more sun the tomato has
had, the better it's
going to be.
So here's a great way of getting
just tomato pulp.
I'm going to poke out the seeds
with my finger, this
great tool.
And I'm going to squeeze
out some of the juice.
And there we go, seeded.
Now, I'm saving the juice
because we're making a cold
tomato soup.
But watch this little
magic trick.
Now we need to peel
the tomato.
What are we going to do?
In one move I'm going
to get tomato pulp
and skin the tomato.
The skin is pretty tough, so
it's protecting my fingers.
I'm using it on the orange
cheese side until I get down
to the skin.
Voila.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Can you skip the
seeding part and just scrape
with the grater and
will it work?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: If you don't
care about having the seeds--
yes, you can.
So the question was, can you
skip the seeding part?
Yes, if you don't care.
Now, why do people take
out the seeds?
Well, it's a change
in texture.
Sometimes the tomato seeds can
be a little bit bitter.
But yeah.
But as you can see, it doesn't
take very long at all.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE], can you
just put it in the blender?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Oh,
great question.
Why are we doing this instead of
putting it in the blender?
Well, because when you put in
a blender, what you get is
this really frothy thing.
And that this is all
about the tomato.
And you'll find that the
mouth feel of this is
just much more pleasing.
And let's say that you wanted
to cook a dish with fresh
tomatoes, like you wanted to
start sauteing, and then maybe
have some beans and a
little fresh tomato.
There you go.
So this actually, this
is the soup.
We're going to add
a little salt.
And we're going to add a little
red wine vinegar.
And if you want, you can add
a tiny bit of olive oil.
Fat carries flavor, but
you don't need much.
And then, you would
chill this.
And then you can do all
kinds of add-ins.
You can top-- we're going
to top it with avocado.
But you could do it
with cucumber.
You could put in shrimp.
You could put in anything
you wanted.
So this is going to be a
fabulous cold tomato soup.
I hope you'll be pleasantly
surprised.
And all of the juices we're just
going to add right back
in there from seeding
the tomato.
Does anybody want to
try doing this?
Any volunteer?
Yeah?
All right.
We got a taker.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Lily.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Lily.
AUDIENCE: Can you add cream
to a cold tomato soup?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Can you add
cream to a cold tomato soup?
Why yes, you can.
Wouldn't that be delicious?
See, she's cooking.
That's how easy it is.
Let's see.
I need some utensils.
AUDIENCE: In this bowl
or another one?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: No, we can
do it right in here.
OK, so you want to get
rid of the seeds.
So let me give you something
to get the seeds out into.
So just poke.
And we won't worry
about straining.
Let's put that right in there.
We'll get rid of this.
Should I time you?
I need the herbs and
so on for this.
And I'll take the other--
I'll take everything seasoning
both of these.
There you go.
She's a master.
Right?
Anybody else want to try the
other half of tomato?
AUDIENCE: I'll try
the other half.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: OK.
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: I'm PJ.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Nice
to meet you.
AUDIENCE: Nice to meet you.
I'm going to go wash my hands.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: OK.
All right, so now
we've got these
gorgeous grilled carrots.
Look at that.
Nice, appetizing.
You could serve them just the
way they are, but we're going
to dress them.
Let's do some--
we're going to do one sort of
Greek or Middle Eastern style.
A little olive oil, a
little lemon zest.
A five-hole zester, very handy
tool for making beautiful,
long curls.
And do you notice that I'm--
here's another big technique.
I'm doing it right over the food
because all the essential
oils are in the colored part
of the citrus peel.
Can you already smell
the lemon?
It's really strong over here.
And let's do a squeeze
of lemon.
And we've got some
chopped parsley.
And let's do a little--
remember we were layering our
flavors and our salt?
It's always nice, even though
these have a little salt in
them, to finish with a
top layer of salt.
Not a lot.
And what I'm using
here is something
called Maldon sea salt.
Can you see those big flakes?
It's a great finishing salt.
It's really nice in salads.
You get a nice sort of clean
burst of flavor.
And since we're doing this
Middle Eastern style or Greek
style, how about a little
feta cheese?
Isn't that beautiful?
What do you think?
Now, this would be great
with oregano.
This would be great with
mint in this particular
application.
This is the app.
But now, let's do a completely
different take.
Let's do something Southeast
Asian instead.
Let's do lime.
I think we need lime zest
too, don't you?
You can turn off the grill.
Yeah, that'd be great.
So a little lime.
Totally different
aroma, right?
You could do fish sauce
if you wanted.
Let's get some lime in here.
We could do red pepper flakes.
But how about--
should we do some sriracha
instead?
That looks good to me.
And how about some cilantro?
Now, I want to show you
something about the cilantro.
And I think having some big
leaves would be really pretty
here, don't you?
What do you think?
OK, same grilled
carrot, totally
different flavor profile.
I'm sure you could think
of about four others.
But what I wanted to show
you is cilantro's really
perishable.
You want to buy cilantro
from a farmer who
leaves the roots on.
It keeps it fresh longer.
That's a careful farmer.
That's a farmer who really
cares about his
crops or her crops.
That's what you want.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
store it?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Pardon?
AUDIENCE: Any tips
to store it?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: The question
is how to store them.
Yes, I do, as a matter
of fact.
I do have some advice on that.
So let's see.
One thing would be with
something like cilantro, just
put it in-- like store it in a
plastic bag with air inside.
Trap air inside the bag.
And then, just keep it
in the refrigerator.
If you want to put any soft
herbs like parsley
in water, you can.
I wouldn't.
But if you wanted to, then don't
put in the refrigerator.
Treat it like a vase
of flowers.
Put it in water and put
it on the counter.
This, by the way, this is a half
a bunch, a half of bunch.
So this is $0.50.
So when you go to the farmers'
market, you get really
bounteous herbs.
You also get gorgeous thyme with
its little flowers, which
goes really nicely with--
any questions so far?
Like before we get into
the next dish?
AUDIENCE: I have a
general question.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So did you decide
ahead of time what you're
going to cook, and then go
to the farmers' market?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: You've just
asked my favorite question.
The question is, do you decide
ahead of time, and then go to
the farmers' market or
the other way around?
It's a little bit of both.
So one of the things
that you do is you
need to know the seasons.
So you'll kind of be thinking,
oh, it's may.
I'm not going to find eggplant
right now, so I'm not going to
have in my mind eggplant.
It's too early for eggplant.
And you're thinking, well, it's
really time for cherries.
And by the way, I'm doing a
great cherry almond salad on
KCRW's "Good Food" this
Saturday at 11:00.
Really interesting way
of dealing with
salad and with fruit.
But I know that it's cherry
season, so I know I'm going to
focus on cherries.
Peaches have started to show
up, but it's a little bit
early for them.
There's a flavor arc.
So I like to think about--
I want to be up here.
When it's early, flavors
aren't as developed.
Things might be kind of tart.
I want to be up here
at the peak.
And then, of course you get
down to the other side.
So I'm going to taste
the tomatoes.
So I'm going to add salt.
I'm going to add a
little vinegar.
So it's all by flavor.
If your tomatoes are very acid,
add a little more sweet,
like a sweet tomato.
If they're not acid enough,
add a little vinegar, or a
little lemon, or
a little lime.
You could make this Southeast
Asian flavors if you wanted,
or Mexican, or Italian, or
anything you wanted.
If it seems too thick,
add some ice cubes.
Oh, that's tasting good.
And just chill it.
The wonderful varieties that
you can get at the farmers'
market-- this is a Pinkerton.
And it's a kind of cross between
a Fuerte and a Haas.
And it has a smaller seed and
a lot of meat in the neck.
And one of its advantages-- did
you see how I did that?
Technique--
is that it holds its shape,
which is nice when you want to
dice it sort of small
to top our soup.
And then if you had a reasonably
sized spoon, you
would just scoop out
all the avocado.
And voila, you have a lot
of little pieces.
Here you go.
So are you getting the idea
of what you want to do?
And so I know you all
got the books.
But my book is available
through my website,
ameliasaltsman.com.
I blog about all kinds of--
all the nexi of food.
Today's blog post that came out,
that went live is sort of
about LA culinary history, and
sort of the surprises.
It's like Scripps olive oil.
You know, Scripps College
produced olive
oil and they won.
They won the international
tasting thing.
But we've been making olive oil
in Los Angeles for over a
hundred years, but nobody
knows that.
So check it out.
So salad.
What we've got are
some incredible,
beautiful salad greens.
I think you get stuff
from Maggie's Farm.
A beautiful mix.
They call this the
charger mix.
And so it's got a lot of
different flavors.
It's got slightly
bitter Frisee.
It's one of the chicories.
It's got radicchio.
It's got this gorgeous
little gems.
So again, texture.
I thought maybe we would do
fennel in this salad.
Are you all familiar
with fennel?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Oh, she's
making a face.
OK.
You're used to like fennel
seeds in sausage?
OK, but this is the
fennel bulb.
This is a female one because you
can see how round it is.
The male ones are
kind of flat.
Sorry, guys.
But you just want to-- and
you like it when it comes
with the tops on.
And you take off the rough
outer portion.
And did you notice
I left a handle?
Now, you can use
this part for--
you can use the fronds, they
taste a little bit anise.
You could use that
in the salad.
You could use that wrapped
around fish
would be very nice.
But one thing that's really nice
and quick is to shave--
to get different shapes,
different textures.
So fennel is a little bit sweet,
but I think it makes a
beautiful shaved element.
And that goes pretty fast.
And look how I'm protecting
my fingers-- multitasking
vegetables.
And then you get this.
Now, you can have a salad just
of the fennel with a little
olive oil or walnut oil
and salt and pepper.
But we're putting it together
with the greens.
You could put it--
there we go.
And spring is radish time.
So this is the late
spring salad.
You notice that the tomatoes
aren't going in the salad
because there's a lot more to
salad than tomatoes, lettuce,
and cucumber.
OK?
And so now we've got all
these beautiful colors.
We could add fruit to it.
We could add cherries to it, but
I think I would probably
add to this salad--
I would probably add
some citrus.
And for a change of pace, do
we have any nut allergies?
No, we're good?
Walnut oil, really nice
with a salad.
It's a good dressing oil.
This is a really nice oil made
by a walnut producer.
Toss the salad right
in the bowl.
OK, no extra dish.
We'll use our crunchy salt.
Do you see how I'm
crushing it?
A little pepper, black pepper.
Optional.
And let's use some more of that
lemon since we've got it.
Nice squeeze.
And toss the salad.
Now, if you had two minutes
to make a salad,
what would you use?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I would use the greens
and the radishes and
yogurt [INAUDIBLE].
AMELIA SALTSMAN: OK,
that sounds great.
She says she'll dress
it with yogurt.
So that would be great.
If I had two minutes, I'd
probably just use the
lettuces, a little bit of oil,
a little salt, maybe
a squeeze of lemon.
If the greens are delicious, I
don't even need the lemon.
And the oil is delicious.
And there is a beautiful
salad.
And then, it looks beautiful
mounded on a platter, right?
What do you think?
Good?
AUDIENCE: I'm getting ideas
for my Thanksgiving table.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Oh,
different season.
We'll have to do this again with
a whole different set of
ingredients.
Well, let's take a look
at the asparagus.
So I wanted to show you
purple asparagus.
Beautiful, right?
When you cut into it--
so I cut them to show you
how beautiful it is.
When you cook them, this purple
asparagus season's
almost over.
But it cooks up, it loses the
purple, but it's like a deep,
deep green.
And it's really sweet.
Do you all like asparagus?
OK.
So another cooking technique,
you can just, almost like stir
fry asparagus in this way.
If the asparagus were whole, you
could roast it or grill it
the way we did.
That's the smallest one?
And asparagus goes really
nicely with butter.
So if you use butter, you
could cook it in butter.
If you didn't, you could
cook it in avocado oil,
which would be great.
And if you wanted to make an
entire dinner in about 10
minutes, what I would do and
have done plenty of times is
I'll cook up asparagus.
I won't even go to the trouble
of cutting it into pretty
pieces, push it aside, crack
open a couple of eggs.
And when it's done, shave--
use a vegetable peeler
and shave big
shavings of Parmesan cheese.
Dinner.
It's good.
All I'm saying.
It's really good.
If the eggs are great and if
the asparagus is delicious.
Put your hand over--
how fast does it gets hot?
That's what you want to know.
Not hot enough.
Any more questions?
Anything you would like to
know about shopping in
farmers' markets, about how
to choose, about how to--
any ingredients we haven't
covered that you'd really like
to know about?
Julie.
AUDIENCE: Are there other
markets you recommend besides
Santa Monica?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: What markets
do I recommend besides Santa
Monica Farmers' Market?
The Venice Friday morning
market is a
really nice little market.
They really have-- it's small,
but it's choice.
The Sunday Mar Vista Market
is a fabulous market.
The Beverly Hills Sunday
Market, also excellent.
I'm trying to think what else
is on the West Side?
Santa Monica.
And then, there are four Santa
Monica markets, right?
And the one on Wednesday
is the largest.
It's one of the largest
in the country.
So we just want that to
cook really quickly.
AUDIENCE: So your recommendation
is the South
Bay market?
AMELIA SALTSMAN:
The South Bay--
the Torrence Market is great.
That's the jewel in the
crown for Torrence,
for the South Bay.
There's also now a market
in Playa Vista.
So I threw in a little
whole thyme sprigs.
Can you smell that?
Do you want to pass
that around?
It's really delicious.
AUDIENCE: Do you ever wash
rosemary and thyme?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: Do I wash it?
If it's dirty.
Touch it.
But yeah, you can just
give it a rinse.
Now, one of the things that I
wanted to say about-- we were
talking about storing herbs.
So when you have a woody herb,
like thyme or rosemary, just
keep them on the counter and
they will dry naturally.
And then they'll be like
having dried herbs.
So for our last little trick--
oh, and I made you a little
cauliflower salad, too.
So for my last little trick, I
want to show you how to cut an
orange so that you get
beautiful slices.
Top and bottom off.
Shave the sides to expose
the back of the pulp.
Turn it, finish the job.
Now, this is if you're in the
mood to do something pretty.
If you're not in the mood to do
something pretty but you're
wondering how they do something
pretty, this is the way.
This technique also works well
for melons when you get--
obviously, you're not
going to segment it.
But if you take the melon, cut
off the top, cut off the
bottom, and go, then it's a lot
faster than cutting a lot
of little wedges.
OK, now what I have--
let's add it right
to our salad.
What do you think?
Just cut between
the membranes.
And there you go.
Beautiful little segments
of orange.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMELIA SALTSMAN: I'm sorry,
I couldn't hear you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AMELIA SALTSMAN: OK,
good question.
What kind of orange is this?
This is a Navel orange.
The Navel season is
just beginning.
And actually, this is a
Washington Navel, which is the
first Navel orange to
come to California.
And this is what made California
famous for oranges.
And we just are finishing
Valencias, which have seeds,
but have a lot of juice.
Although, this isn't too bad.
Now, do you see I'm getting
like a book of membranes?
And then when you get all the
way through, you can just--
we'll just squeeze the orange
juice right on top.
All right, any other
questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So I guess this
is a loaded question.
But what would you prefer,
buying not organic at the
farmers' market or going to a
store for organic [INAUDIBLE]?
AMELIA SALTSMAN: So the question
is about organics.
This is what I like to do.
So when something is certified
organic, it just means one
simple thing, which is that the
farmer has complied with a
certain level of growing
practices.
Many farmers who aren't
certified organic farm at a
much higher level of sustainable
farming practice.
Well, that just makes it a
little bit difficult, right?
For the consumer.
So for me, I do the following.
Number one is that I
start shopping and
engaging the farmer.
And the easiest way to know what
a farmer is like and how
he or she grows is-- we're
coming right back to the
beginning--
flavor.
It's really hard to grow
for flavor first.
So anybody who does that has to
have really good practices.
It is a guarantee?
No.
But you have to grow
the soil first.
So you have to be a dedicated
farmer who really is nurturing
and nourishing the soil.
Terroir--
It's about what the soil gives
to the food, not just wine,
anything that grows
in the ground.
So it influences how
our food tastes.
If you choose a variety that
its marker is flavor as
opposed to shipability or
storage or perfection, it may
not be the easiest
thing to grow.
But if you care enough, you're
going to grow for flavor.
You're going to choose that
variety because you're a
really proud and passionate
grower.
And the other thing is that if
you grow for flavor, you are
going to wait till
the last minute.
You saw how juicy
that orange was.
That orange is stored on the
tree, not in a shed.
The months that it stays after
its first beginning-- remember
that arc over here?
It's just continuing to gain
flavor from the warm sun and
then the cold nights, which
gives us really good contrast.
That's why we have such amazing
produce in California,
it's that Mediterranean
climate.
So I go by flavor.
And then I ask questions.
So for me, that's how
I make my decision.
If I were at a supermarket, I
would probably just make sure
that I was buying organic
because that's the only
touchstone I would have.
That's the only guide
I would have.
But my preference would be to
buy from growers that I know.
Did I answer your question
in full?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
AMELIA SALTSMAN: When it's
grown locally, it
means it's in season.
So it's easy.
If it has good flavor, it's
going to tend to be good for
you, well grown, good
for the planet.
So it's not that hard to
do all the things we
really want to do.
I'll just close with this--
the most important thing we can
do for ourselves and the
planet is to cook from scratch
from well-grown ingredients.
If we cook for ourselves,
we will be healthier.
And if we cook with good
ingredients, the planet will
be healthier.
So that's what it takes.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AMELIA SALTSMAN: So I hope
you'll come and taste.
And I'd be happy to sign your
books if you would like.
In the side dish section,
there's a whole primer for
roasting vegetables--
what temperature, how long,
whether you need to
blanch it or not.
So it's a whole guide.
Because really, it's all about
a little olive oil, a little
salt, and a sheet pan.
You are good to go.
That is life's answer.